bonjour je vous en prie Jean-Marc Ayraud
installez-vous merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ancien Premier ministre et
nouveau président de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès et on va bien sûr en parler
d'abord un mot puisque évidemment
maintenant vous regardez cette actualité
avec du recul avec un regard différent
sur ce qui se passe du côté des
États-Unis ou Emmanuel Macron est en
visite des tailles l'évoquer ce
programme d'investissement et de
subventions de Joe Biden pour aider les
entreprises américaines à assurer la
transition énergétique à lutter contre
l'inflation et il a dit que ça risquait
de fragmenter l'Occident alors cette
nuit jobiden s'est voulue rassurant en
parlant de l'Europe mais est-ce qu'il y
a vraiment un risque aujourd'hui de
fracture de l'Occident sur ces questions
selon vous c'est pas seulement une
facture de l'Occident qui est en qui est
une menace c'est que chacun ce que ça
soit le chacun pour soi et c'est vrai
que nous sommes dans une période
extraordinairement compliquée et même
dangereuse la crise énergétique après
avec la guerre en Ukraine bouleverse
complètement tous les équilibres et donc
la tentation pour se protéger c'est le
protectionnisme alors je dis pas qu'il
faut pas se protéger qu'il faut pas des
règles le désordre mondial n'est pas non
plus une solution mais il faut faire
très attention et tirer le centre de
l'histoire et l'histoire c'est la grande
crise de 1929 et ses conséquences
malheureusement terribles donc je crois
que c'était bien que Emmanuel Macron le
fasse non pas seulement au nom de la
France mais aussi au nom des Européens
parce que les Européens la politique
commerciale vous savez est géré par
l'Europe par l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne sur cette question en
train de prendre conscience qu'il faut
se protéger davantage mais ça peut se
faire aussi que dans le cadre
multilatéral et aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il y a une crise de multilatéralisme
la question se pose aussi à la Chine qui
ne respecte pas toujours les règles du
jeu du commerce international donc il y
a une organisation du commerce
international qui est l'OMC et qui est
pas toujours bien utilisé qui fonctionne
pas toujours bien parce que ces membres
parfois bien s'abstiennent de respecter
les accords qu'ils ont eux-mêmes signés
les règles de l'Union européenne sur ces
questions affaiblissent l'Union
européenne doit être un peu plus
protectionniste
surtout qu'elle a une stratégie de
politique industrielle et ça c'est
vraiment très important il faut que on
puisse alors on a vu que la crise du
covid avait montré certaines faiblesses
de l'industrie européenne notamment du
médicament donc il y a une prise de
conscience qui est en train de se faire
mais je pourrais citer un autre des
domaines qui est celui de la défense les
industries de défense et sont très
faibles en Europe chaque nation la
France l'Allemagne d'autres pays ont des
industries de défense et et la question
de la relation franco-allemande dans ce
cadre-là est essentiel vous savez bien
que il y a eu tout ce débat ces derniers
ces dernières semaines sur une crise de
la relation franco-allemande on l'a
illustré par la panne du projet d'avion
du futur la viande défense et puis c'est
en train de changer c'est à dire qu'il y
a eu un espèce de sursaut
franco-allemand qui va plutôt dans le
bon sens mais vous voyez il faut arrêter
de penser que on va s'en sortir chacun
pour soi le cadre européen et à mon avis
le plus approprié mais faut-il encore
qu'en Europe on est des vrais débats et
[Musique]
en Allemagne qui sont extrêmement forts
en ce moment y compris au sein même de
la coalition que gouverne donc si il
faut comprendre le partenaire donc on
souhaite que les Allemandes comprennent
mieux nos difficultés nos débats à nous
nos choix nos réflexions nos attentes
mais il faut aussi que nous on soit plus
attentif à ce qui se passe en Allemagne
que ce couple
français allemands
parce que ça veut pas dire grand-chose
dans l'occurrence c'est la relation
franco-allemande qui est une nécessité
historique des deux côtés est-ce que
l'Allemagne n'est pas plus pro Allemagne
que à regarder les relations
francophones
est-ce que la France n'est pas trop pro
française donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
dépasser ces sentiments là ces réactions
là je pense quand en ce moment les
Allemands avec leur industrie sont
extrêmement inquiets l'opinion publique
allemande est extrêmement préoccupée
mais quand je vois vos reportages je
vois que en France aussi on est très peu
occupé par une question très très
concrète c'est est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
se chauffer en hiver et pas seulement se
chauffer dans nos logements mais est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir continuer à faire
fonctionner nos services publics est-ce
fonctionner nos entreprises bon bah la
question se pose aussi en Allemagne et
donc la réponse et la crise de la covid
nous l'a montré c'est pas le chacun pour
soi et donc la réponse elle est commune
alors il y a des efforts pour arriver
mais vous avez vu que pour le
plafonnement du prix du gaz c'était très
compliqué parce que c'est une caution
compliquée donc il faut en débattre et
quand même un état d'esprit qui soit de
trouver des solutions communes et la
tentation vous souvenez pour la faire
des vaccins c'est que ça s'assoit le
chacun pour soi et c'était parti comme
ça ça aurait été terrible et puis
finalement il y a eu un sursaut il y a
eu un sursaut qui est dire mais on va
passer commande ensemble il faut tirer
les leçons c'est une très bonne
expérience et puis vous vous souvenez
que face à la crise économique qui
suivait la crise sanitaire il y a eu un
grand plan d'investissement et de
relance qui a été décidé à l'échelle
européenne avec une lampe un emprunt
commun ça c'était une vraie révolution
faut continuer dans cette voie on va on
va parler de l'Union européenne mais
d'abord un mot puisque vous parlez de la
question de l'énergie entre la France et
l'Allemagne qui sont maintenant un peu
dépendantes l'une de l'autre sur le gaz
sur l'électricité la France qui va
importer l'électricité pour la première
fois depuis des années est-ce qu'il y a
eu des erreurs dans la politique
énergétique française est-ce que ça a
été une erreur de vouloir diminuer la
part de nucléaire oui enfin on est loin
d'avoir
un objectif qui ce qui est en soi un
problème mais il faut que le notre nos
centrales nucléaires qui
qui est à patrimoine de la République de
la nation française fonctionne bien et
c'est là que le bât blesse parce que
diminuer la part du nucléaire ou des de
l'industrie fossile de des énergies
fossiles c'est une nécessité de diminuer
les énergies fossiles mais pour les
remplacer par les renouvelables c'est
toujours une nécessité pour vous ce qui
compte c'est de faire fonctionner le
parc tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et ce que
je constate c'est que ce parc ne
fonctionne pas à plein s'il fonctionnait
à plein nous n'aurions pas le problème
que vous venez de d'évoquer qui nous
nécessite d'importer de l'électricité je
rappelle aussi que nous nous exportons
du gaz en direction de l'Allemagne donc
là on voit de solidarité mais est-ce que
c'est pas aussi dur un investissements
il faut tirer la leçon des sous
investissements qui se sont produits
pendant une longue période dans le
nucléaire ça c'est très vrai on a perdu
un savoir-faire on a été longtemps le
premier
industrie au monde du nucléaire on a
même négocié des accords de partenariat
avec la Chine je me suis rendu en Chine
à l'époque où j'étais Premier ministre
pour commémorer ses accords 30 ans après
et mais là on a perdu un peu la main et
donc de fait d'avoir perdu la main
d'avoir sous-estimé la nécessité de
certains investissements de maintenance
et de rénovation d'autre part on le paye
aujourd'hui alors on est en train de
corriger tout ça tant mieux mais on a
pris un peu de retard
les hésitations politiques des choix de
gestion de court terme et je pense que
c'est pas que ça je crois pas que dans
le cas d'une équerre français ça soit le
cas je pense que c'est une perte de
savoir-faire de nos industries d'une
manque d'ambition et c'est ça c'est la
politique industrielle derrière qu'il
faut
interroger et revisité mais je pense que
nous avons besoin de temps long vous
savez une centrale nucléaire si on la
Gère trop à court terme on va avoir des
problèmes mais c'est la même chose par
exemple des raffineries de gaz de
pétrole par exemple donc on voit que ce
sont des investissements extrêmement
coûteux en politique il faut faire
attention de ne pas être toujours dans
le court terme et le court terme on est
tenté par ça il faut aussi toujours
penser moyen et long terme moi je
préside aujourd'hui une fondation la
Fondation Jean Jaurès je sais ce que on
peut se donner du temps du temps long
parce que on n'est pas là dans l'action
politique proprement dite et on a besoin
de concilier les deux et vous voyez bien
alors avec le développement de des
réseaux Internet Twitter et tout ce qui
va avec que on est sous la pression du
quotidien mais presque des l'immédiateté
et donc ce qui rend la décision
politique extrêmement affaiblie et il
faut la renforcer par de la réflexion
par du Moyen et du long terme et
justement on va parler de votre
fondation jeanjass puisque vous venez
d'en de la présidente en quelques mots
d'abord quel est le but de cette
fondation c'est un espace de réflexion
de débat il y a plusieurs fondations de
ce type en France il y a la Fonda Paul
qui est bien connue et le font gabyle
Fondation Gabriel Péri la Fondation
Schumann puis on a quelques autres aussi
et la Fondation Jean Jaurès
est une fondation qui a inscrit son son
histoire le nom la rappelle dans le
socialisme républicain et elle
appartient à la famille sociale
démocrate européenne
elle est indépendante des partis
politiques elle est ouverte à tous elle
est
déclarée d'utilité publique dans tout ce
qu'elle produit comme idée comme débat
comme réflexion comme proposition chacun
peut s'en emparer et elle est ouverte et
accueillante à toutes les sensibilités
de la gauche quel que soit leur
positionnement politique donc on est
indépendant mais on veut jouer notre
rôle donc ce qui fait par exemple que
vous avez pu voir ces dernières semaines
qu'on a publié un rapport sur les jeunes
et le travail sur les jeunes et
l'entreprise parce qu'il y a des
mutations profondes dans la société ne
perçoit pas toujours et qui fait que les
propositions politiques des partis
politiques sont souvent décalées par
rapport à ce que les Français pensent
donc la crise de ce covid a accéléré ses
mutations ces changements de
comportement donc nous on est là outil
on va lancer pour 2000-2023 alors je
vais retrouver tout à fait la formule
une grande étude sur les fractures
françaises que nous avons déjà faite
mais nous allons réactualiser pour
savoir où en sont 18 mois enfin 18 mois
après le début de la guerre en Ukraine 9
mois après le début de la guerre en
Ukraine que les français où sont les
contradictions françaises les fractures
françaises et ce que les Français
attendent et ça ça sera le deuxième
volet d'une autre étude parce qu'il y a
un lien entre la guerre en Ukraine et
les fractures françaises bien sûr tout a
changé le monde a changé les rapports
entre les pays ont changé et vous
évoquez tout à l'heure le risque
professionnel c'est c'est une
conséquence de ça donc il faut
comprendre comment les Français visent
ce qu'il ressent ce que j'appelle les
fractures nous appelons les fractures
françaises ou en sommes-nous pour bien
comprendre qu'elles peuvent être les
propositions politiques et après qu'un
deuxième grande étude que nous lançons
pour l'année prochaine quelle est la
société rêvée des Français au fond
quelles sont parmi les différentes
catégories de français les aspirations
n'ont pas pour additionner ces
aspirations mais pour voir où sont les
convergences possibles pour un projet
commun parce que effectivement il se
projeter dans l'avenir une espèce de
société on va dire idéale pour
utopique on va dire pour les les
décennies à venir mais qui permettent de
construire des offres politiques et que
les partis politiques peuvent intégrer
dans leur propre réflexion avec des
observatoires on a des observatoires que
nous avons mis en place qui sont bien
connues on va en ouvrir un nouveau qui
est l'Observatoire sur les migrations
pour prendre un peu de recul et pas
aborder ces questions toujours sous
langue uniquement polémique et
politiciens on a besoin oui bah j'ai cru
comprendre que c'était le cas y compris
sur votre antenne il y a quelques
instants et c'est pas uniquement par la
polémique et par l'invective qu'on
réglera des problèmes qui sont complexes
donc les fondations sont là pour se
tendre réflexion ce temps long et puis
aussi de créer les événements par
exemple la semaine prochaine nous nous
avons un événement avec cartoon for
Peace
que nous organisons à la Fondation Jean
Jaurès nous allons recevoir un
dessinateur de presse ukrainien donc ça
sera une manifestation de solidarité
avec jésus-chrenia sous l'angle de la
liberté d'opinion la liberté de la
presse la question démocratique il y
aura un débat animé par Pierre Aski puis
j'aurai aussi l'occasion parce que c'est
une question très importante de recevoir
la présidente de mémorial c'est une
organisation russe fondée par Sakharov
sur la mémoire des victimes du
stalinisme des camps et qui a été
interdit par Poutine et qui n'a plus le
droit d'exister et de faire son travail
en Russie et le travail de mémoire je
préside aussi la Fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavage c'est une
question essentielle et nous accueillons
un sujet d'ailleurs un mot là-dessus
vous savez notre héritage commun notre
héritage on va dire dans notre
imaginaire et aussi toutes les
discriminations les préjugés les
stéréotypes ça vient de quelque part et
si on comprend pas notre histoire et la
Fondation Jean Jaurès travaille aussi
sur l'histoire
ne comprend pas le présent et on n'est
pas capable de préparer l'avenir
justement vous parlez de vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la social démocratie
elle a encore un avenir cette sociale
démocratie pour
lui donner des des associés à des
propositions concrètes crédibles pour la
société d'aujourd'hui parce que
aujourd'hui ah c'est insuffisance qui te
proposer par les différentes parties
politiques qui s'inspirent de cette
histoire
démocratie aujourd'hui elle est présente
en France avec le Parti socialiste bien
sûr dedans ou à côté
c'est pas un parti communiste c'est pas
un parti trots donc il s'inspire de
cette histoire du socialisme républicain
qui est propre à la France mais aussi
qui appartient à cette grande famille
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure de la
sociale démocratie européenne donc la
Fondation Jean Jaurès travaille avec
d'autres fondations et en particulier
des fondations sociales démocrates comme
l'Allemagne Friedrich eibert je
rencontre son président dans quelques
jours nous avons des projets communs
donc on voit bien que il faut réinventer
le projet social-démocrate qui est un
idéal en l'époque en France cette
sociale démocratie pas toujours pas
toujours il y a des pays où elle est un
peu disparu notamment dans l'Europe
centrale Europe de l'Est et puis elle
est très forte encore dans l'Europe du
Nord mais vous voyez qu'elle est aussi
en difficulté en Suède c'est pas si
simple en Allemagne elle a été dominante
elle a aussi baissé même si elle a un
chancelier social-démocrate donc partout
en Europe moi je constate que la sociale
démocratie a besoin de se ressourcer
serait interroger parce qu'il suffit pas
de dire on est social-démocrate et on
est de gauche et on est progressiste etc
et il faut que les solutions apportées
correspondent aux attentes profondes du
peuple et il y a des mutations dans la
société le fait d'avoir perdu un
électorat ouvrier par exemple doit
interpeller la sociale démocratie parce
que le phénomène est partout même dans
toute l'Europe et au parti socialistes
on va est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la
social-démocratie en France ce sont les
1,7% d'amidalgo à la place
c'est quoi les aspirations sociales
démocrates c'est la question de
l'égalité la lutte contre les
discriminations de l'aspiration à une
société plus juste plus solidaire et
puis c'est aussi la capacité à prendre
en compte toutes les grandes mutations
du monde et notamment en particulier
l'une qui est centrale qui est la
question du réchauffement climatique et
ses conséquences pas seulement
climatiques mais aussi social
c'est-à-dire si on s'y prendre n'importe
comment si on fait n'importe quoi ça
sera extrêmement dur pour une partie des
Français et c'est notamment les plus
modestes donc comment faire face à ce
défi et comment régler la question de la
justice sociale qui reste une aspiration
fondamentale donc ce que je trouve pas
de réponse aujourd'hui dans le pays
est-ce que les politiques répondent à
ces questions
pas assez parce que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure très souvent dans
la tactique très souvent dans le court
terme et qui ne donne pas de perspective
qui donne du sens et qui donne de la
confiance et je pense en particulier à
la jeunesse qui aujourd'hui est déçu et
qui d'ailleurs souvent s'éloigne de de
l'acte électoral souvent celles qui
s'abstient le plus et c'est pas
forcément par désintérêt par négligence
parce que beaucoup de jeunes s'engagent
sur d'autres d'autres formes mais il
faut répondre par un projet politique
c'est je vous parlais tout à l'heure de
ce que je fais la Fondation Jean Jaurès
notamment ce grand chantier de la
société rêvée des Français c'est un peu
un chemin que nous allons proposer et
après ça sera aux forces politiques de
son emparé quelle qu'elle soit et en
particulier bien sûr à gauche je vous
l'ai dit nous sommes ouverts et
accueillants à tous mais ça sera à
chacun de prendre ses responsabilités la
Fondation Jean Jaurès est un bel outil
nous le mettons à la disposition mais le
Parti socialiste il a tourné le dos
aujourd'hui à l'associal démocratie pour
vous non mais il est en crise donc il
est en train de s'interroger il aura
réglé ses propres problèmes il a son
congrès vous voyez bien vous suivez
l'actualité moi je m'inscris pas dans
dans les jeux tactiques internes je
reste à mon à ma responsabilité
sociale et c'est aujourd'hui grosso modo
il y a trois lignes il y a une ligne pro
Nupe représentée par des effort il y a
une ligne anti-up et il y a une ligne un
peu entre deux l'avenir du PS il passe
par quelle ligne et par les idées par
les propositions qui seront
enthousiasmantes et pas par le jeu que
tactique mais c'est break pour toutes
les forces politiques aujourd'hui
ne produit plus assez d'idées il y a pas
de projet il est en train de de se
confronter à ce défi et il faut qu'il y
réponde mais c'est pas la faire que du
Parti socialiste regardez la crise
démocratique elle touche toutes les
formations politiques et quelle est la
formation politique qui répond vraiment
à ça regardez les écologistes par
exemple ils ont voté pour désigner leur
représentants leur dirigeants ils ont
voté à 5000
c'est pas grand monde et donc si vous
regardez le LR donc qui sont en train
d'agir leur président c'est la même
chose mais si vous regardez le parti
présidentiel c'est pas glorieux non plus
donc où sont les forces politiques qui
pourraient répondre aux aspirations
elles sont à construire elles sont cette
question est devant nous donc c'est pour
ça que un rôle une fondation comme la
Fondation Jean Jaurès travaille sur le
fond travail sur les questions
fondamentales et essaie d'éclairer le
débat et après ça sera à chacun de
prendre ses responsabilités parce qu'il
faut les prendre ses responsabilités
parce qu'on a pas le droit de laisser en
jachère en quelque sorte et en
déshérence une absence d'offre politique
parce que pendant ce temps-là ce est en
train de monter c'est le populisme il
est partout le populisme c'est pas qu'en
France il est monté partout en Europe
aux États-Unis mais même en Afrique où
j'étais il y a peu de temps notamment au
Sénégal où j'ai pu percevoir ça que
souvent quand on a pas d'idées quand on
a un mec par contre qui a une crise et
une crise de confiance et une angoisse
le populisme est là pour faire croire
que il a ses solutions alors qu'il en a
pas et que ce qu'il propose est
extrêmement dangereux pour l'avenir de
nos démocraties mais ça ne marchera que
ça ça marchera que s'il y a absence
d'une offre politique à à la place et ça
c'est le rôle des grandes organisations
démocratiques actuellement selon vous
c'est absolument arrivé de l'extrême
droite au pouvoir dans l'année parce que
l'extrême droite est essaie de se faire
passer pour normal banal en rasant les
murs en quelque sorte et en rassurant
pour faire croire qu'au fond les comme
les autres et ce qui n'est pas vrai ce
qui n'est pas vrai et ce qui est
dangereux pour notre République et pour
nos démocraties c'est pas vrai qu'en
France vous avez vu les élections au
Brésil où là la société extrêmement
clivée coupée en deux c'est la même
chose aux Etats-Unis et l'histoire n'est
pas terminée et donc les grandes
organisations ou même les petites
organisations démocratiques doivent
davantage prendre leur responsabilités
et sortir des jeux tactiques et
délétères et les invectives le bruit la
fureur n'est pas un programme politique
il faut apporter aussi des solutions
mais il faut aussi apporter de
l'enthousiasme il faut apporter de
l'espérance et ça c'est encore devant
nous on doit y répondre par les partis
politiques aujourd'hui selon vous dans
une démocratie on a besoin des partis
politiques mais les partis politiques
s'ils sont que des machines électorales
sont souvent mutation source de
désillusion oui il faut vraiment faut
les ressourcer peut-être les revoir dans
leur organisation à faire des
organisations plus ouvertes plus souples
enfin la crise des militantes si il faut
rester militant la preuve en tout cas
plus ouvert plus à l'écoute plutôt les
rang entre soi d'abord et puis avec les
autres plus ouvert sur la société vous
avez été longtemps mais de Nantes
évidemment Jean-Marc Ayrault aujourd'hui
vous voyez ce qui se passe à Nantes
l'insécurité augmente notamment
notamment est-ce que vous reconnaissez
encore votre ville aujourd'hui ecoutez
ne soyons pas caricatural il y a des
problèmes de sécurité il faut les
traiter ça sèche chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités cette responsabilité il
faut qu'il soit articulé entre l'État et
la collectivité locale c'est une
politique publique qui d'abord une
politique régalienne mais elle doit
aussi être mise en oeuvre en lien avec
le terrain et donc avec les maires c'est
pas vrai qu'à Nantes et cette question
de la sécurité il faut la prendre très
au sérieux c'est pas une question
secondaire dans les études que fait la
Fondation Jean Jaurès on voit bien que
c'est une préoccupation qui monte mais
attention elle est souvent liée à une
dégradation du de ce qui se passe
notamment avec le trafic de drogue et ça
concerne des grandes villes pas
seulement Nantes si on regarde la
situation française mais ça concerne
aussi maintenant des villes moyennes
même parfois des petites villes et donc
ce qui gangrène la société et qui crée
de l'insécurité crée de la violence et
c'est pas que la France regardez la
Belgique regardez les Pays-Bas qui sont
confrontés à cette question et moi je
vois là le problème principal qui est la
cause de beaucoup de dérive c'est
d'insécurité et donc il faut qu'on se
faire une affaire collective et non et
non polémique en permanence si on pense
pas que collectif si on passe par
responsabilité collective alors on y
arrivera pas et donc il faut abandonnée
ce terrain de la sécurité c'est possible
que dans certaines tendances politiques
on est sous-estimé mais moi je kiffe qui
était maire pendant très longtemps à la
fois Saint-Herblain 12 ans enfin 3 ans à
Nantes je peux vous dire que comme je
connais bien les mers et en particulier
les maires de gauche ils n'ont jamais
sous-estimé la question de la sécurité
c'est peut-être au niveau d'un discours
politique national que parfois les
choses étaient moins claires mais en
tout cas je peux vous dire que les mers
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui qui se préoccupe
de la question de la sécurité parce que
la il faut la prendre au sérieux c'est
une inspiration légitime démocratique
c'est dans la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 donc il y a pas à faire
à faire croire qu'il aurait les uns qui
seraient meilleurs sur cette question
que les autres je pense que la situation
que se dégrade il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités mais qu'on le fasse
ensemble qu'on se dise bon comment s'y
prend ensemble collectivement ensemble
état mairie et puis à l'intérieur de des
villes et des communes qu'on le fasse
aussi ensemble et pas seulement toujours
en en faisant un sujet de polémique et
de fracture merci Jean-Marc ayant merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin on va passer au club des
territoires